the art I make is interactive
installation work or that's one way to
describe it because what it does is it
takes input about the space so in this
instance or in a lot of instances I use
a video camera to watch people moving in
a space and then I write software that
generates a visual output based on input
and so what it feels like when you're in
an installation is that the visuals are
just responding to your body very
seamlessly so it's interactive in a
sense that's always changing based on
what's happening in the space everything
that happens in the projection is based
on movements so generally if you start a
work there's nothing there or there's
kind of a base there of elements in the
system that have their own behaviors so
really when I make a piece it's almost
like creating a whole environment so I
think of all these different visual
marks also have a kind of animated
behavior and then other rules about how
they might react like when they
intersect where a person is or in some
cases they like attract to your
trajectory or you know there's all
different kinds of rules that I write
about how these marks react to things
but then there's a number of different
behaviors later together to create the
composition of the piece
so one of the earliest interactive
installations I created was a
collaboration with Romeo assitive and
the piece was called Tex train and
that's one of the more literal
installations so the cameras in the wall
so that what you see in the projection
is like a big black and white video
mirror of yourself and there are letters
raining down and that you can actually
catch with your body and the letters are
a poem so eventually you can read
certain words you probably never read
the whole poem but you get the idea that
it's not random that there's something
here that's sort of just outside your
grass
another piece I did that I really like
is called the good time it's actually a
whole series and in that piece your
movement in the space fragments
pre-recorded video so as you move you
start the video moving or rewinding but
only in certain parts of the screen but
so my idea was to subdivide the actual
playback from the video frame and place
smaller units so that creates this
really strange rippling and warping of
time as you move around in a space so
these are ink drawings and charcoal
drawings that I made that eventually
became part of the untitled six project
so I knew I wanted to have some elements
that appear along people's trajectories
and those these are also the elements
that start growing into the big blobs
and I was trying to make them you know
computationally on the computer and I
just it turns out it's much easier to
get the kind of variation just using ink
for me anyway than to try to figure out
how to do that mathematically or using
something like Photoshop so I scan these
in and then pick the ones that I want
that I think look good in the piece and
then those are manipulated in terms of
the color and their size and their
orientation with the software that runs
the piece
some of the newer Commission's I've been
working on
don't use projection they're using LED
lights more in a sculptural form and
I've just been brainstorming a lot about
what does that mean for how we consider
light in our world